all right
Angela Merkel is Germany's first female
leader and very much a woman of her time
she's both reassuringly conventional and
an enigma
she grew up in East Germany before the
fall of the Berlin wall and speaks
Russian better than any other foreign
language she's a scientist by training
but climbed quickly up the ranks of the
center-right Christian Democrat Party
after German unification
she was first the Protege of Chancellor
Helmut Cole
for most of her time in office Merkel
has governed in a grand Coalition with
the main opposition party the SPD
Germany's equivalent of Labor shall be
remembered for steering Germany through
crises relatively unscathed it remains
one of the richest countries in Europe I
mean she came to power the German
political system was intensely male and
in the end she showed that she had the
staying power the determination and the
grit to outlast all the men who were
there at the time she became Chancellor
she continued the economic reforms of
her socialist predecessor and as the
biggest player in the European Union she
saved the Euro while putting Germany's
interest first
her attitude to the rest of the world is
balanced Germany still under spends on
defense but joined the NATO forces in
Afghanistan
she resisted David Cameron's attempts to
charm her with visits to Checkers and
box sets of mid-summer murders denying
him the renegotiation which he thought
could defeat brexit this is one of the
things she really understood from the
beginning the the complexity of Europe
of 27 or 28 Nations working together and
you have to find compromises and that
you will not get something until you
unless you give something really big
back and the Brits were not willing to
give something back she was openly
disdainful of populists like President
Donald Trump and decided to stay on as
Chancellor after his election does we
can do it she told her people far from
ending freedom of movement her most
dramatic Act was to agree to admit more
than the million refugees during
Europe's migrant crisis of 2015.
after 16 years in office Angela Merkel
is retiring the most dominant European
politician of this Century so far